pete demelitis who likes a good
conspiracy theory even more than i do
although let me tell you based on recent
events
i don't like conspiracy theories at all
anymore
trust me on that but pete suggests that
the taylor
contract was done and announced
yesterday morning
to take attention away from what the
washington post
eventually reported late yesterday
morning
about the settlement of the lawsuit that
had not yet been filed but
was poised to hit the court system
regarding the videotapes that
had been allegedly created and this was
a washington post report from back in
august
outtakes from cheerleader shoots
calendar shoots that there were certain
outtakes that were
over the top that were uh frankly
containing
feelings of nudity yeah and they get
spliced together allegedly
for viewing by high-level executives
with the team
that litigation was never filed because
it has been
settled and the key that it was settled
yeah
when the lawyer representing the
football team
says the matter has been resolved those
five words
are very very common as the
accepted script the extent to which
anyone can say anything
when a case is settled with a strong and
broad confidentiality provision no one
is allowed to talk about it
and so that everyone is on the same page
the only thing that anyone can
say when asked is the matter has been
resolved i've
signed off on negotiated been involved
in
plenty of settlement agreements that had
that provision that said the only thing
anyone can say is the matter has been
resolved
so when i saw that the washington
football team's lawyer
used that phrase yes it was resolved
and yes a fairly large check presumably
was signed by daniel snyder to resolve
those claims seems that way
i mean it also seems like pete and you
talk too much so that's that's one thing
but what is
first off i i don't think that taylor
heineke had anything to do with right
you know i mean you don't you don't buy
into that that was like a
a curve ball like look over here we
signed tyler heineke don't pay attention
to that story
pete says pete says when you google
washington football team it's all
heineken stories that pop up
that's interesting okay now now let me
ask you the next thing
like this being settled dan snyder
i would think is under the microscope
from the
shield in the nfl a little bit this a
good thing
a bad thing i mean what do you what's
your take on it here johnny lawyer
if anything it's neutral to bad because
one of the items that came out in this
just bizarre dysfunctional back and
forth and there's different levels and
layers of fights that are happening and
the fight between daniel snyder and
his limited partners the the the
report came out at some point in
december it's hard to keep it all
straight because there's been so much
involving that organization over the
past seven months
but the report came out at one point
that there was a sexual
impropriety allegation made and it was
settled for
1.6 million if i remember the number
correctly right
and and and there there is
cash value in keeping
a case from and so
you know it's one thing to say okay what
are the facts
what are the damages that were suffered
by the plaintiff
what is this case worth every case
has a value and if you can set aside the
personal feelings if you can set aside
the acrimony
there's a way to look at it and say
here's what we think a verdict would be
based upon these facts here's the range
here's what we're going to spend to
defend the case the case has a value and
it's
reasonable minds are going to differ on
what the value is but there's a value
yeah right the thinking is that keeping
the case from being
filed has value because
you don't want all this stuff out there
you don't want it all playing out in
court
you don't want testimony you don't want
the vid god you don't want the video to
be shown not that it would be shown in
open court but
but if you're dan schneider you want to
be dragged through this and there's a
fine line
a fine line between
the settlement of a case with an element
of
you're buying silence and you're not
going to have to deal with this
and you're not going to have this all
public and it's not going to embarrass
you and your family
there's a fine line between that and
blackmail and extortion
right and and and in a weird sort of way
the the settlement of these claims
before filing
a lawsuit is a legal brand of extortion
because you're allowed to do it you're
allowed to do it these are rights that i
intend to
to advance in court and this is this is
a a proper
exercise of my civil justice rights
and if you want me to not do that here's
what it's going to cost you
and again there's a fine line between
that extortion but that's what happens
all the time especially with high
profile people who don't want to be
embarrassed and have their image
tarnished by the the substance of the
lawsuit chris
yeah i'm right i mean it all makes sense
i mean it definitely does the next thing
i want to ask you because i'm just
interested to hear your take and you
always have good feel with this stuff
um where do you think daniel snyder
like where do you where do you think he
lies in the nfl right now i mean
that's it's it's still i mean there's a
lot of stuff going on with that
organization over the last
year well you know is he warm and cozy
down there you think the nfl is happy
with him right now and how things are
being run in that washington
organization
i think back to what happened with jerry
richardson and how swiftly he handed in
the keys to the car now
he turned around and sold the team and
and and then there are people that are
upset
like whoa he shouldn't have been able to
sell the team and make all that money
well he still owns the team
yeah i mean like and somebody made that
argument with me about snyder it's like
well it won't be right if he has to sell
the team and he's going to make all this
money it's like well
well i mean what how how much can you
punish the guy yeah right you're forcing
them out you're giving
away all your money because of what
you've done yeah
you can't you can't say we're seizing
your assets
right we're seizing the team from you
the most they can do is force him to
sell that's the ultimate in dignity and
yeah he's going to make a lot of money
if he has to sell
but he doesn't want to sell i mean
that's the one thing i've repeatedly and
consistently heard here he is hell bent
making sure that his kids take over the
team someday he doesn't want to sell it
he wants to continue to run it but
when you look at what richardson was
accused of doing and richardson had four
or five confidential settlement
agreements involving behavior that
traced back
to him personally with schneider
a lot of this dysfunction has been
brushed off to others in the
organization now you could argue he's
still the
the top of the of the pyramid he's the
guy who's setting the tone he's the guy
who's putting these people in place
who are creating these dysfunctional
episodes but
the the stuff with the videos what it
all comes down to what beth wilkinson
found remember she's the lawyer who was
initially hired by snyder
to investigate the team and i had
concerns about that because it's never
independent
if you're being paid by the team to
investigate the team and investigate the
owner and he's the guy writing your
checks
but the nfl eventually took over that
investigation
and there's just always been a vibe
they're not gonna go after him and you
you get a sense from the nfl when
they're really motivated to go after
someone
right and when they're not there's never
been a vibe that they're really
motivated in going after daniel snyder
and forcing him to sell the team
so we'll see what the final report
is but i'm going to view the final
report through that lens
of they have consistently created the
impression they are not
going to force the guy to sell the team
over this and i can't help but wonder
frankly whether or not that attitude is
influenced by
the reality or the possibility that
you know wherever you set that bar
there's going to be
others in the club i hear you
potentially are going to find themselves
in the same boat yeah
that that you're right you set a
precedent so now you got oh gosh now
another owner or something like that and
all of a sudden you look like
it's not they're not yeah you said that
you set a precedent for facts that have
already transpired yeah right where guys
didn't know where the line was
and they're already once the allegations
come out they're already on the wrong
side of it and then you give more power
to those who would make these potential
civil
allegations hey we got a lawsuit we're
going to file against you
how much do you want to pay us to not
file that lawsuit right all of a sudden
the price of that goes up yeah yeah that
it all makes sense uh going to be
interesting yeah but you're right and i
you know i know we got to go to break
here but i i do
like you you get the sense that the nfl
whatever is just
the attack dogs are not on washington
that they're gonna let this play out and
let it go
and it just doesn't seem like anything
major is gonna happen
yeah and i really cause i remember when
the stuff went sideways for jerry
richardson
i remember thinking yes like they're
going to force
out he's not the last right and that
he's not
the last that if if having entered into
confidential settlement agreements with
employees who made claims
that there was any type of impropriety
committed by the person who
you know is a billionaire and may feel
like he can do and say whatever he wants
and some of these guys who are older who
may have
you know they grew up at a time when
things that were acceptable then are
clearly not acceptable now
you're going to have others he's not
going to be the only one and i i
remember seeing reports from people i
think charles robinson of yahoo had a
report that they're scared to death
about how this was going to play out and
how many others were going to end up in
the same boat and i'm surprised
that you know three four years after the
fact snyder's the only one but
depending upon what they do with snyder
it could put others in a delicate spot
and i think that's where they're
that's where snyder may be benefiting
from
uh you know a a greater degree of
lenience than we would have expected
because i think there's concern that and
who knows
who i'm i don't know i don't know and i
think they don't want us to know and one
way they keep us from knowing
is to not create an incentive for others
to come out of the woodwork
and say well yeah this owner did this to
me that owner did this to me
and you know before you know it you got
for sale signs all over the nfl right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports